[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
MICHEL DEGRAFF: We're so
glad that we can welcome Jean
Casimir, Professor--Pwóf!
TiJan Bosal.
So his name is actually--
I love the name--
TiJan Bosal.
And I think you will get to
hear more, perhaps, about--
JEAN CASIMIR: The only one
who called me like that.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: Well,
that's your name on Twitter.
That's his handle on Twitter,
is @TiJanBosal, which has--
which is quite
loaded in symbolism.
JEAN CASIMIR: Yes.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: And
that's why I love it.
So I can say that
the entire semester,
all of our discussions have
prepared us for his visit
in many ways because the
topic of this class, Jean,
TiJan Bosal, it's really
about the use or the misuse
of language in the way we create
our identity or the way we
misidentify ourselves,
vis-à-vis our compatriots,
vis-à-vis the world.
And as we saw, actually,
through each of them
you get to hear
how, growing up, we
are socialized into
certain beliefs
about language that can
either give us power
or can remove power from us.
And then we've
discussed various ways
in which we can
regain that power,
or we can keep that power alive.
And that's what your work is
all about in the particular case
of Haiti.
So we've read parts of your
book and through chapter 8
on the beauty and the power of
the sovereign people of Haiti,
where you show so clearly the
key importance of language.
As you call it, it's
a living archive.
Because when you
write about people
who have been oppressed,
people who have been excluded,
where do you get your archives?
Because they didn't
write the history.
History is written by the
Europeans, by the winners.
And one way to recover that
history is through language,
and in the case of Haiti,
through Kreyòl, right?
And that's one of the main
aspects of Jean's work
that I feel is extremely
important for me.
And for me personally,
why Jean is so important,
in terms of my own
liberation, it's
because this is
what I grew up with.
So I grew up with this textbook.
So this is my history textbook.
This is where I learned
the history of my country.
And it's actually-- it's
quite amazing to think of it.
I think of the concept that
you brought up yesterday,
on Monday, of "deformation,"
the point that colonized
people, either in the
Caribbean, or Palestine,
are deformed through
historical factors--
yet Haiti is a proud,
independent country.
In the Caribbean,
people know about Haiti.
In fact, there are songs
written about Haiti,
about Haiti's struggles
for independence.
Yet Haitians like
myself, we learn history
from a book that
received the imprimatur,
the approval of what?
If you read here,
this is the imprimatur
of the Catholic Church.
So the Catholic Church
is the institution
that approves the
version of history
that teachers teach us
about our own history.
And then the part
that's very striking
is the preface, which I put
here because it's so striking.
And I'm just going to read
the bottom part of it.
So here it says: "The
mean people will teach you
how to detest evil
and the good people
will teach you to honor virtue.
And then our heroes will
teach you patriotic pride
and the price of liberty."
And we have to admire the
efforts of Las Casas, Boutin,
Alexis-Jean-Marie Guilloux, the
value of souls for eternity.
Now does anyone know
about Las Casas?
So tell me, Merelin, what
do you know about Las Casas?
AUDIENCE: I know
he mostly resided
in the Dominican
side of the island.
He was basically
a priest, kind of,
but he was also a history
person, a historian.
He was an author.
He kept track of
every single thing.
He was very much pro-Indigenous.
And he tried to defend them,
but just basically recording
history.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: Yes,
actually that's a good point.
So Las Casas, he was
very much pro-Indigenous.
And he was so
pro-Indigenous that what
he did when he knew that the
Indigenous people were dying
off, they were dying of yellow
fever, of various abuses,
of genocide.
He thought that the best way to
save the so-called Indians is
to bring in the Africans,
because he had this theory that
Black people are--
in fact, he invented
the notion-- well,
they invented the
notion of Blackness,
that Blacks are
destined for slavery.
Therefore let's
bring the Africans in
to save the Indigenous people.
He said that was the deal he
made with the powers of Europe.
So he was a major promoter
of the slave trade.
And this is who,
we're being asked,
in the name of virtue to
honor and to adore Las Casas.
And the others,
Boutin, Guilloux, they
are missionaries, basically.
You see?
Do you see any name of a
Haitian freedom fighter?
There is no Dessalines here.
There is no Toussaint here.
There is no Boukman here.
You see?
And this is what
we have to adore.
And then it says at the
end, "Love this little book
and be docile to its lessons."
[LAUGHING]
Yeah, be docile to the
lessons of the book.
You see, so that's
our history book.
Now this is a literature
book, a literature book
written by a French
brother called--
Catholic brother
called Raphaël Berrou,
and a Haitian linguist
called Pradel Pompilus,
a well-known Haitian linguist.
And one of the favorite
authors in this book
is Carl Brouard, who wrote--
this is something
that the priest
would have us recite by heart--
that the question of
Kreyòl is ridiculous.
What development can Haiti
expect from its Kreyòl?
Kreyòl will be
nothing but a patois.
There is nothing
to do about this.
And then it goes
on to say, parents,
never speak Kreyòl
to your children.
French is a habit that
you are to develop.
Therefore, be pitiless in
correcting your children
when they use Creolisms.
You see?
So do you imagine a country
where most parents speak only
Kreyòl?
That book asks that
parents never speak Kreyòl
to your children.
Do you imagine?
So it means really that if
they were to follow this,
they would just--
they would never
speak to the children.
They have to-- this is--
So this is just as
background to tell you why.
And actually, this is more,
actually, of the same.
So this is my report card
from Saint Louis de Gonzague.
Actually you went-- were you
at Saint Louis de Gonzague?
JEAN CASIMIR: I studied at
Saint Louis de Gonzague.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: So we
share that same school.
So Jean Casimir went to
Saint Louis de Gonzague.
Maybe 50 years apart?
Maybe, I don't--
JEAN CASIMIR: No, no, yes,
but I spent three years
in Saint Louis de Gonzague.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: OK, OK.
So do you remember
these report cards?
They had colors.
JEAN CASIMIR: Oh, yeah, yeah--
MICHEL DEGRAFF: They
were color coded.
They were-- let me
try to remember.
Pink for very well--
Oh, green?
I don't remember the color.
But it was color coded.
So this was--
I was a good student, right?
"Très bien," very well.
But this is the cost
of this "très bien."
You have to adhere
to these directives.
So basically, students
have to be present.
You cannot bring
weapons to class.
Knives are forbidden.
You cannot loiter.
And then rule number four, the
use of Kreyòl is prohibited.
You see that?
So to be "tres bien," you
better not speak Kreyòl.
So now to move on to today--
so that's why I've been so,
so happy to bring in Casimir--
and here, I want to give thanks
to the history unit at MIT.
I want to give thanks
to MIT Global Languages.
And also Global France is
also sponsoring Jean's visit,
and MIT Haiti also is
sponsoring Jean's visit.
And so Jean gave this
talk on Monday [5/2/22].
Vivian [Sansour] was there
and it was an amazing--
really an amazing
talk, which you
might get to hear more
about today [5/4/22].
But really what Jean
is teaching us to do
is how to reread
Haitian history, not
from the perspective of
the Las Casas, the Boutin,
the Guilloux, the brothers
of the colonial instruction.
He's asking us to
reread Haitian history
from the perspective of
the formerly colonized,
from that of the captives.
And he's doing-- and Jean is--
I like to say that Jean
is one of the rare,
very rare Haitian intellectuals
who've been producing texts
in Kreyòl for--
Jean, actually when was
the first text you produced
in Kreyòl on history
and sociology?
When was that?
JEAN CASIMIR: I'm
going to tell you,
in the '70s, in the journal
"Sèl with the fathers and the--
I don't remember the--
I have it at home, actually.
I found it now.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: Yeah,
that's avant garde.
That's really
forward thinking that
in the '70s, that was before
the famous Reform Bernard.
JEAN CASIMIR: Oh, yes indeed.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: That
was before that.
We had this reform in '82
that basically said, look,
the schools are failing
Haitian children.
We have to use Kreyòl as
a tool of instruction.
And before that, Jean was
producing text in Kreyòl
on history.
And we're very pleased that
Jean has so happily agreed
to translate some of his work
in Kreyòl that we're putting
on Platform MIT Haiti.
And so actually we
spent time today
discussing the next
article that will
go with that very topic,
"decolonial versus colonial."
So that's why I
feel really honored.
And we should all be pleased
to have Jean with us today.
So this is actually--
And I love this, it says
technology in the lakou--
the lakou is this communal
unit where we Haitians live.
That's where we get
our sovereignty--
where we trigger protest,
the kind of protest
that can actually
lock down a country.
"Peyi lok" is the term that's
used in Haiti when there's
a protest, you
basically shut down
the country out of protest.
And that twokèt, what Jean does,
which is actually very relevant
to our work here-- and I can
think of what Gabby is doing
for her project--
is how to use technology
to be able to move
social change forward.
And in this twokèt, he
talks about how Haitians,
even very poor Haitians-- or
very impoverished Haitians,
I should say--
managed to use the
phones, WhatsApp,
to be able to create protest.
So in a way, that's a
bit what we're doing:
using technology like in
the platform to push forward
the Kreyòl movement.
And I wanted to-- because
Jean used to work for United
Nations--
how many years did you spend,
Jean, working for the UN?
JEAN CASIMIR: I spent
15 years working there.
But I was the representative
of Haiti at UNESCO.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: You were?
JEAN CASIMIR: Yes,
but I never went.
I resigned before going.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: OK, OK.
This is great.
This is great, Jean, because
I'm going to show you what
your successor is doing now.
JEAN CASIMIR: Yes.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: Dominique Dupuy.
I call her "Anbasadèz
pa m" [i.e.,
"my favorite
ambassador"], you know,
because she's
doing amazing work.
But UNESCO, what
I want to show you
is to show you the
power of hegemony,
and how hegemony
even affects science,
because UNESCO is the unit
for education, science,
and culture at the UN.
And UNESCO's basic mission is
to promote linguistic diversity
and equity and human rights.
Yet in UNESCO's recent
survey for the Atlas
of World Languages,
look at this table here.
They ask each country
to check the box here
based on their language.
And so here are the
choices: Either you
speak a linguistic isolate, or
you speak a language, "langue,"
or you speak a mixed language,
or you speak a Creole language,
or you speak a Pidgin language.
So there is a
concept of language
without any adjective,
that's the unmarked category.
And then if you speak
Creole, then you're
basically in a
separate category.
And when you look at
the guide for the atlas,
it tells you that a
Creole language is not
on par with a language.
Why?
Because it comes from a Pidgin.
That's the argument,
that because Creoles
come from Pidgins,
therefore they
don't belong to that category.
You see and something
which I see there's
loads of evidence, data
analysis, against that.
So I want to close by
showing Jean's successor,
many years after Jean--
This happened in early April.
So basically what
she did was amazing.
She challenged
UNESCO's categorization
of Creole languages.
And let's just listen to this.
And then it's going
to be your turn
to tell us more about
your work in this class.
Let's play this.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[END PLAYBACK]
MICHEL DEGRAFF: So as
we speak, as we speak,
I'm looking forward to hearing
from Ambassador Dupuy about how
UNESCO at last is responding.
Because at first
they said, "Well,
our experts tell us this
is what Creoles are.
We have to trust our experts."
But she's been pushing back.
JEAN CASIMIR: Which experts?
Which experts?
Tell us which experts?
MICHEL DEGRAFF: Exactly.
So but now actually, in
the past couple of days,
there's been some
back and forth.
And I'm hoping maybe
before the meeting ends--
in fact, I just sent her
a picture of this now--
to remind her that we are here
waiting for some result of what
she's doing.
So I think that should
give enough context
as to why this person that we
have here is so, so important,
both for me personally,
but also for us, fighting
for emancipation really.
So let's go around the room
and introduce ourselves
to Professor Jean Casimir.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I'm Jazhara--
MICHEL DEGRAFF:
Actually, I think
we're told that with the--
with the mask, it might be
a bit-- so as you speak,
if you could just remove
it, and put it back,
but just when you speak.
And you can put it
back afterwards.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I'm Jazhara Solan.
I'm from Jamaica,
and that's the reason
why I was so interested
in taking this class.
My project is on
the role economics
can play in forming the
opinions on different languages.
So it usually tends
to be-- the rich
tend to determine what language
is acceptable in society.
And so I'm researching that.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: All right.
Any questions for Jazhara?
JEAN CASIMIR: No, I mean
the only question I can see
is that--
well, I don't know if this
is a compliment for you.
But as far as I'm
concerned, Jamaica and Haiti
are so similar, they look
like twins, you know?
And I say the only
difference is that Jamaica
was under the British, who were
coming up with their empire.
And we were with the
French going down,
so we've got independence.
The only difference
is they, not us, no?
And what is
important for Jamaica
and for myself also is
that we have a language.
Now I had a Jamaican
professor, friend of mine,
good friend of mine, historian.
He said Jean, when
I am in Jamaica,
people speaking Jamaican,
I don't understand them.
He was genuinely Anglophone.
He can't speak Jamaican Creole.
And I will give--
I could give you
endless example now
of this Creole giving the
note of a different country.
And Jamaica is
certainly the country
where you have the free
village system established
and acknowledged by the empire.
That's quite important,
that's what I call
the counter plantation system.
AUDIENCE: So my name
is Rachel Robinson.
I'm also Jamaican.
Oh, the mask--
And so I was interested
in taking this class
because I've never really
had the opportunity
to take a class like this about
Caribbean identities and Creole
languages.
And I didn't really
know too much about it.
And I thought this would
be such a great space
to learn more about it.
Throughout like
my life I guess I
would say I've
had some struggles
with my Jamaican identity, and
knowing my history, my culture,
and like really
claiming it as my own,
given that I wasn't born there.
And I just-- I just
don't know as much.
So this class has helped
me a lot in growth
in really claiming
it, and getting
more excited to learn
more, to reach out
to my parents, my grandparents,
my family members, and things
like that.
So one of the projects
I did in this class
was about our identities.
And I kind of talked
about my struggle.
And this was earlier
on, so I hadn't
made as much growth I
think as I have now.
But I just talked
about different things
that I struggled with,
and ways that I want
to try to fix that and grow.
And yeah, that was probably
like my favorite thing
that I've done, because it
just was so almost healing
to talk about myself.
And I put a lot of
pictures of my family.
And that was just
really nice to see.
Yeah.
JEAN CASIMIR: I don't
have much to add
except that, for instance, the
production of music in Jamaica
and in the Caribbean--
I don't have to add,
I just mention that.
And you can imagine
the rest, to tell you
the beauty of the sovereign
people, because it's not
music from the high
classes that make Jamaica--
that put Jamaica on the map.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: That's right.
AUDIENCE: Hello,
I'm Iana Ferguson.
I'm from St. Vincent
and the Grenadines.
I took this class because
I grew up in St. Vincent,
so I've always had knowledge
of Caribbean history
from a Caribbean
person's perspective.
So I was interested
to see how it
would look from an American's
perspective in this class.
And so that's why
I took the class.
My main project in the class is
examining the linguistic chains
in the Caribbean.
And the running theme was
the song "Redemption Song"
by Bob Marley.
So I used the lines,
"Emancipate yourself
from mental slavery, none but
ourselves can free our minds."
And that was my main
idea for my project.
So I'm investigating why
people in the Caribbean
speak the way that they do.
JEAN CASIMIR: St. Vincent is
a very, very special country.
Actually, St.
Vincent is the link
between the Amerindians and
the African-born people,
with the Garifunas in Belize.
You can imagine St. Vincent.
And the Garifunas in
Belize, which are Belizeans,
their lost paradise is St.
Vincent, it's not Africa.
And if they call us
Creoles, the Black
coming from the Caribbean,
because they are distinct.
They are from St. Vincent
and they are Garifunas
and they are the living
presence of the Caribbean--
of the Caribs, sorry.
And St. Vincent has some
other interesting aspects
also with regard to Creole.
When the British
took over Trinidad,
I mean when the Spaniards
gave Trinidad to the British,
the British could not
put order in Trinidad
because the police and the
population speak Creole.
And the British always
thought that the police
and the population were
"de connivence"-- what
is that in English?
MICHEL DEGRAFF: Conspiring--
JEAN CASIMIR: --conspiring
against the British.
So they did, they had a set
of Bajans and Vincentians
come at policemen because
they were monolingual.
So that helped the British.
No, but-- that is another--
[LAUGHING]
MICHEL DEGRAFF: Language
can be used as a tool for--
JEAN CASIMIR: Oh, yes.
You see what I mean?
And also now they feel at
ease because the Bajans
and the Vincentian
do not speak Creole.
That gives them
another opportunity.
But St. Vincent is very
important for this.
It also, ah, the co-presence
of Black Caribs and Red Caribs.
And this is in itself also
very, very, very important.
They have a way of calling the
Caribbean plantation America.
So what do we have to
do with plantation?
Plantation is a
European institution.
I mean, so let's see the
diversity within our countries.
You see, and that's a very,
very, very diverse country.
AUDIENCE: So my name
is Merelin Maldonado.
I was born in the
Dominican Republic.
I've lived in New York
for about 12 years now.
And I think my main
reason behind taking
this class is that
I have grown up
in a very Dominican
neighborhood, a very
Dominican household.
So I had very, I wouldn't say
negative, but more tolerant
ideas about Haiti.
And I wasn't really that
knowledgeable about Haiti.
But I wanted to
learn more, you know,
sort of like de-indoctrinate
myself from what
I had known before.
And because of
that, in this class,
I've gotten the chance to learn
more about Dominican Spanish
through my own research.
But also we were able to
read The Farming of Bones
by Edwidge Danticat.
And I really like getting to
interview the people around me
and seeing, what
they actually know
about the history
between DR and Haiti,
because I barely knew anything.
And I just wanted to
look more into that,
and just seeing how
much we don't know
and how much more
work we have to do
is just so surprising to me.
And yeah, I think that's
why I took this class.
JEAN CASIMIR: Well, as I was
telling you before we started,
the DR and us--
well, I still would say we are
two wings of the same bird,
even though this sentence was
used for Cuba and Puerto Rico.
But that's the fact,
we live together.
We are the--
I think the only case of two
countries in the same island.
If they are two cases in the
world, we are one of them, no?
But what is interesting
is how we have increased
the diversity of the Caribbean.
When I spent 10 years in
Trinidad working with the UN,
and my friends in the
academic community
think of in terms of
plantation America.
And they would say free village
societies and Bush Negros
and counter plantation,
this is marginal.
The core of development is-- no,
I mean if you take that line,
you have equality
at the end of time.
You will never reach--
because plantation
is what plantation is, a
capitalist institution,
economic institution.
While, to face that
institution, we
had created all the things
like the bush societies,
like the free village system.
And the place where
you can see that
is the DR, because,
when you see the DR,
this is what Columbus
started, washing away
all the old Tainos and all,
ah, vestiges of pre-Columbian,
what you imagine as
pre-Columbian civilization.
And then starts a
set of coexistence
of remnants of
the Spanish group,
the poor Spaniards who could not
follow with Cortez toward Cuba,
et cetera, no?
Then the Spanish
Blacks, Latinos,
who were enslaved in Spain and
came to the Dominican Republic.
Then a set of enslaved
they imported from Africa,
then a set of
runaways from Jamaica
who went and established
themself in Santo Domingo, all
these before even
the French took over
in the western part
of the country.
You see what I mean?
And this will give
you a type of society.
What is also very important
and interesting in Dominican
Republic is that they have
that Spanish tradition
of the ejidos.
Ejidos is a form of
communal ownership
of the land, which
the Amerindian had
and the Spaniards conserved it.
And this gave a certain
freedom of the population
and an element to negotiate
the plantation system.
Well, and the DR
brings something back
to the diversity
of the Caribbean.
The Spaniards came back.
I mean they recolonized the
country, not during long,
but enough to do much harm and
to establish white supremacy,
not only in the country, but
in the head of the oligarchy
of Saint-Domingue.
And this reconquest will be done
against the Haitian position,
which had abolished
obviously slavery,
et cetera, et cetera, at a time
when Cuba and Puerto Rico still
had slaves.
And one of the problems
of the Spaniards
is that they said, "You
want to enslave us?
No way!"
You see what I mean?
This is very, very interesting.
And it's very important.
It's not to such an extent
that in the DR and in Haiti,
they are brothers and sisters
and they have no problems.
But the two oligarchies,
they are like cat and dog.
They can't stand each other.
But underneath they
are very friendly.
And they are making
their money quietly.
But you should hear them.
So they prepare the
population to hate each other.
This is their job, to
make us fight, et cetera.
I think that you have
a very good position
to observe the diversity
of the Caribbean
and the importance of the
non-plantation system,
even though you have
probably one of the best
actual systems of plantation.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: There's a book
called Why the Cocks Fight.
JEAN CASIMIR: Yeah?
MICHEL DEGRAFF: So it's a book
about the history of the DR
and Haiti.
As you mentioned, they
make sure that they fight.
JEAN CASIMIR: Oh, yeah, yeah.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: Why?
Because when you go
to the cockfighting,
the humans are the ones
making the cocks fight.
The cocks don't want to fight.
The cocks are not
meant to fight so much.
So it's such a
powerful metaphor,
that the DR and Haiti,
why do they fight?
Why they fight,
basically like why
the cocks fight, because they
have other people pushing
them to fight Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I'm Gabrielle.
And I'm Jamaican.
And I took this class
because I really
don't know much about my
people's history like that.
So anything that says Caribbean
culture lessons or something,
I was always
interested in because I
was raised by my mother.
And although she has fun stories
about school life in Jamaica
and stuff like that, she
never really told me much
about the history of Jamaica.
So I only knew
surface level stuff.
And I wanted to go in more.
And my project was on how
European nations to this day
have some type of economic
power in the Caribbean,
despite them trying to form
their own economic power,
and how Europe kind of uses
hegemony to build off of that.
And I thought that was
pretty interesting.
JEAN CASIMIR: It is indeed.
I must say that Jamaica
has probably the best
historians of the Caribbean.
Yesterday I was
privileged enough
to have dinner with
one of them, which
is Vince Brown, Vincent
Brown, who just came out
with a tremendous
book you certainly
have all read now, Tacky--
MICHEL DEGRAFF: Tacky's Revolt.
JEAN CASIMIR: I mean one
of the best stories of how
the Africans in the Caribbean
fought for themselves
and maintained themselves.
Jamaica has this peculiarity
of having forced the British
to recognize this difference.
And this is to my
mind very important
how we have been able
to defend ourselves
to keep our differences
and to reproduce it.
So what you have is that, for
instance, one of the reasons
why Haiti was independent,
I mentioned the fact
that the British was going up.
But the other reason is that
when in 1804 and the French
was--
before in 1791, when the
French were in crisis,
60% of the Haitians
came from Africa,
was African-born people.
And it is those people
"Tacky's revolution"
is describing, a set of people
coming straight from Africa.
You see what I mean?
So this gives you an idea of the
conservation of an identity you
have received in your village.
And here, the
opposition you have
against the system that is--
and how are you finding that.
But in between, what
is important, and this
is where the Caribbean appeals,
is that you come from Congo,
you come from--
you are Ashanti, you
are Wolof, you are Zulu,
you know what I mean?
And we all are coming
to becoming Jamaicans.
So the process of
unification is where
we are going to create a new
identity, which is Caribbean.
While, to follow your--
the institution
created by Europe
wants you to be
homogenized individuals
without a community,
without an identity proper.
So you are supposed
to be British.
For instance, I was one day
with two of my great friends,
both of them.
But one of them is from the DR,
the other one from St. Lucia,
and really high-level persons.
And the friend from the DR
say, oh, we are Afro-Latin.
I say, I beg your
pardon, because
in the English-speaking
countries,
it's nearly an offense to tell
somebody they're Afro-Saxon.
[LAUGHTER]
And she defined
herself as Afro-Latin.
And I say, well, me,
I'm no Afro-Latin.
What are you, then?
Well, I happen to be Caribbean,
Caribbean, and Caribbean,
full stop.
[LAUGHS] There is no
Afro-Saxon, no Afro-Latin.
We are Caribbean.
In our diversity--
and this is what
makes us really peculiar and
different from any other form
of Blackness, you know what I
mean, no matter where you go.
Well, I will not expand
on that because--
MICHEL DEGRAFF:
It's fascinating.
JEAN CASIMIR: Yes, yes indeed.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: So
Gabby made a TikTok--
talking about the
technology and peyi lòk.
So should we watch
Gabby's TikTok together?
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
OK, so what is CARICOM?
CARICOM, shorthand for
the Caribbean community
and common market, is
an organization made up
of the Caribbean
and Latin Americas
to promote economic
growth and integration
with the rest of the market.
On their own website,
they describe themselves
as developing countries
who have connections
to markets in both
North and South America.
So their goal? basically, to
be taken seriously and get
Caribbean economies
on the market.
However their plan of
execution is essentially
to sell themselves
to the ones who
matter the most in the
game, European nations.
Their "Who we are"
statement on their website
kind of seems to
confirm this, as they
describe their community
as multilingual,
and go on to include
English, French, and Dutch
as their main languages.
Now the language portion
of this is really important
because it is very
symbolic when it
comes to colonized-and-colonizer
relationships.
In the Caribbean, for
example, most people
speak some Creole
or Patois derived
from a blend of Indigenous
and African languages,
as well as the language
of their colonizer.
These languages, despite
being common tongues,
are often treated as lesser.
And the most prevalent example
of this is Haiti's relationship
with the French, who--
surprise, surprise!--
has had a stake in
keeping Haiti a country.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
Haiti's government has had
a history of disregarding
their mother tongue of
Kreyòl, despite it being one
of their two national
languages [ed. note:
"two official languages"].
The second one,
take a wild guess.
Funnily enough, roughly
5% to 10% of Haitians
can actually speak
French fluently,
and those are usually the elite.
Considering the active push
in schools to speak French
by literally only
teaching in French,
you can see why schools in
Haiti aren't exactly thriving,
and why they needed to join
CARICOM in the first place.
So Haiti, like the
rest of CARICOM,
wants better economic
opportunities
for their country
and their people.
Yet the French seem to
be getting in the way,
as they have
historically always done.
So Haiti needs out
of the disparities
the French have put them in.
Yet French rely on Francophone
countries to keep them relevant
and in power.
So what do they do?
Money.
They throw money
at the situation,
and then declare
that they know best.
JEAN CASIMIR: That's impressive.
Wonderful.
AUDIENCE: It's funny, too.
That's what's so good about it.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: Well
done, well done.
JEAN CASIMIR: "Have
a wild guess"!
[LAUGHTER]
MICHEL DEGRAFF:
Vivien, you're last.
AUDIENCE: I'm Vivien.
Hi, I'm Vivien.
And I'm in this class--
I'm from Palestine.
And I have been over the last
decade and a half of my life
working with peasant communities
in recovering ourselves
through recovering
our seed heritage.
And so I'm very
interested in imagination
and how our
imagination can help us
in the journey of liberation.
So for me, the Caribbean is
such a rich place to learn from
and to understand from
other people's experiences
that have a lot of
similarities, and obviously
a lot of uniqueness to it.
How do we find our power
and our beauty in them?
And how can our beauty,
as we uncover it--
we've been told it's ugly--
how can we really
accentuate our beauty,
if you can extract it again
to regain power in ourselves.
So I find a lot in the Caribbean
for me, and the beauty of it,
and the beauty of also finding
power inside the wounds
that we have.
That's why I'm in this class.
JEAN CASIMIR: Thank you, Vivien.
I will not comment on that.
No, no, no, no.
I mean, this is very
important because in fact, I
think the results of the work
I've done in the book we have
in front of us is that our
sole wealth is our imagination,
because if you take
the people coming
from Africa in the Caribbean,
we are the majority.
Now we came like worms.
We had just nothing.
And we are individuals,
naked, naked individuals
with no contact, nothing.
There doesn't
exist an individual
in the world who is alone.
I mean an individual is--
comes from a community.
So the first thing we
built was a community.
But building a
community was exactly
opposing the power of the
plantation system, no?
With what did we
build the community?
With our mind, with
our imagination.
To give you only one
example, the European family
is based on private
property, no?
The definition of an enslaving
[INAUDIBLE] is he or she who
cannot possess anything that
does not belong to his master.
So obviously we had nothing, no?
Yet we create family.
We find a way of
bypassing this element.
Obviously our families will be
called non-family, promiscuous,
or all sorts of things.
They try to deface the
product of our imagination.
And up to now, up to now, they
cannot cope with our family
system.
If there are two institutions,
products of our imagination
that are defaced,
vilipended, that we despise,
it's voodoo and family.
And they are the less
understood institutions.
All over the Caribbean, we
call it the "Shango Baptist,"
call it "Obeah," no matter.
They don't even know what
they are talking about.
And family, they don't
understand family, our family.
For instance, in
Haiti, family is
supposed to be, ah,
patriarchal, matrifocal--
God knows what,
all sort of names.
They don't know what it is.
They just don't know what it
is, because, let's see, you
know what happened-- just
to finish this comment.
Two persons in any countryside
of Haiti, old people,
they go to church,
they get married
because they are
celebrating their 50
years of living together.
This is when they get married.
They don't get married
to have the right
to go to bed with one another.
No, no, no, no.
After being to bed, after having
their kids, their grandkids,
et cetera, et cetera, et
cetera, now the whole village
is going to celebrate
their marriage.
I mean you see our
conception of wedding
is not the western
conception of wedding.
How could we have that if not
imagining another institution,
working in another
setting, creating a story?
Or this is that wealth
that bothered them
because we are different.
And a friend of mine in--
not a friend, but a professor
in a Zoom of the Catholic Church
said, listen, what my
problem is the following.
If you are a people
that is being exploited
by some big master, you will
tend to look like the master,
so you can defend yourself.
He's saying that.
But you people, from the
beginning you say no.
So how did that happen?
You see what I mean?
Obviously this is
what I'm telling you.
We were-- from the
beginning, we were not
from this line of thought.
The problem is how are
we going to maintain
that identity we had, no?
Well, the difference
is that we could not
because we came
like individuals.
So we have to create
another community.
And this community
is Caribbean made.
It is not from Africa.
It is not from Europe.
It is local.
You see what I mean?
We create something in
difficult condition,
and we are still there.
We do have problems.
I cannot prove to anybody there
that Haiti is not the poorest
country in the world,
put it that way.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: Most
impoverished, I like to say.
JEAN CASIMIR: But like
some of the people
said-- and by the way, a great
Caribbean man, Lloyd Best,
said this is the most
developed country of America.
As far as Lloyd
Best is concerned,
as far as imagination, as far
as self-confidence, as far
as identity, as far
as fighting to stay,
because we could disappear,
other nations have disappeared,
the Taino disappeared.
We could disappear.
The Haitian probably
will disappear.
But the day we forget
our basic values,
it is when day when we
disappear, not before.
I will not speak of my
friends from Palestine.
They are on the verge of,
and we are on the verge of.
I mean we are on the verge
of, but we will disappear.
But you have in the Caribbean,
for instance, in Dominica, cave
called "La Cave des Indiens,"
the cave of the Indians, where
they found together the
bones of 200 Indians who
killed themselves.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: Wow.
JEAN CASIMIR: Yeah, with
the manioc, with the--
MICHEL DEGRAFF: Poison?
JEAN CASIMIR: Poison,
they poisoned themselves
because they do not want and
cannot live under the Spanish,
the Spaniards.
In Mexico, there is also a
wonderful example of El Cañón
del Sumidero.
El Cañón, the canyon,
Sumidero is well.
Well, what happened is that
this group of the First Nation
is fighting against
the Spaniards.
And the Spaniards' army is
coming and they just cannot
win.
So they put the kids, the
ladies, and the warriors.
And they are fighting
and they all--
they retreat, they retreat.
Everybody fell into the Canyon.
And up to now, you
can visit Mexico.
You will visit the
Canyon del Sumidero.
I mean certainly there
has been genocide.
But the point is that we have
chosen a collective suicide.
I mean this is how we lived.
You see what I mean?
We prefer to live like that
instead of bending our head.
We have done that already.
So OK, we are fighting.
We are poor.
We are weak.
But we ain't going
to lower our head.
And this is--
I say Caribbean because I'm
talking about the Caribbean.
But I'll give you an
example of Mexico.
And I'm sure you will
find that all over, Mexico
with the arrival of.
So one of the points that,
in fact, unite us here it
is that we have never thought
we were second to nobody, never,
never.
And we cannot think that.
This is why we say equality
is the starting point.
It is not the goal.
We have to plan on the
basis that we are equal.
So I mean, we have in Haiti
a long tradition of contact
with the Palestinians.
In fact, the right arm of
Aristide at some point in time,
may he rest in peace.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: Izmery?
JEAN CASIMIR: Izmery,
he was Palestinian.
And oh, yes, indeed.
And well, he was
with us in the fight.
And he died for that also.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: So what's
your project about?
Can you tell us
about your project?
AUDIENCE: My project?
MICHEL DEGRAFF:
Yes, for the class.
AUDIENCE: Which one?
MICHEL DEGRAFF: The
one you want to share,
the one you want to say.
AUDIENCE: I have been
extremely interested in Vodou.
And actually, I'm
learning a lot about Vodou
in terms of spiritual
practice, but also finding
a lot of parallels
that I'm finding
with practices in Palestinian
heritage that are being--
we're being told are not
right to think in that way.
Like our imagination
and our spirituality,
whether it's through
people who dream
or people who
relate to nature as
also a source of information,
through also being taught
by the Catholic schools and
all the religious institutions,
that this is not the
way we should think.
And that this is primitive
and we should throw it away.
And so I'm interested
so much in Vodou
because it's also another
way of knowing the world
and being in the world
that is very liberatory.
And I think there's
so much wisdom there
that can really improve
our ability to live,
not just in dignity, but
also with other beings
that we are equal
to other beings.
And I feel like this is an
urgent learning for today.
So I am--
I've interviewed a priestess,
a manbo, who is wonderful.
And she's a great storyteller.
So it also shows
how telling stories
and how stories are so
important in knowing ourselves.
What is the story we tell
ourselves, and the ability
to create a new story like
the lakou and, you know--
And so I am exploring
that also with myself
and my own dreaming.
JEAN CASIMIR: Yes indeed.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: Yes, thank you.
That was great.
So thanks to all of you for
sharing such personal aspects
of yourselves.
So now it's 1:00.
So technically we're supposed to
enter the second part of this,
which is Jean, you
will introduce,
say a few words about the
chapter 8 that we all read.
Then we go around the room
and we each ask a question.
But I wonder whether it's
a good time for a break
before, because--
what do you think, Tom?
What do you say?
CAMERA OPERATOR: That's how
you usually do it, right?
MICHEL DEGRAFF: Yeah,
so let's take a break.
Let's see, it's 1:00, so let's
come back at 10 after 1:00.
It's 12:58, 10 after 1:00.
And then, OK, so get some
coffee, stretch your legs,
and come--